ربما لا يوجد كلام يقال في فاجعه يوم امس
لكن لعلنا نذكر نحن ايضا في صباح العربيه
ضحايا الكارثه التي اصابت تركيا وسوريا
فبقوه 7.9 درجات اهتزت الارض تحت ساكنيها
بزلزال كان مركز مدينه غازي عنتاب واصاب
سوريا التي كانت الاكثر تضررا بعد تركيا
ووصلت ارتداداته الى لبنان والعراق ومصر
واليونان وقبرص وارمينيا الزلزال المفجع
خلف الاف الضحايا في تركيا وسوريا فضلا عن
ملايين المشردين الذين دمرت بيوتهم بعد
انهيار مئات المباني بينما يبقى العشرات
حتى الان تحت الانقاض في مشهد مرعب يعيش
سكان جنوب تركيا وشمال ووسط سوريا
والمناطق الساحليه السوريه بعض المراجع
تقول ان هذا الزلزال هو الاكبر في تاريخ
تركيا منذ نحو قرن وهي التي شهدت في
السنوات الاخيره نشاطا زلزاليا ملحوظا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]